انسحب الاحتلال من مخيم طول كرم بعد عمليه
عسكريه استمرت 46 ساعه قام خلالها
الاحتلال بتدمير البنى التحتيه في داخل
هذا المخيم وفقا لمؤسسه الخدمات في مخيم
طول كرم التي اكدت تدمير بين كلي وجزئي
لاكثر من 1 وحده سكنيه داخل مخيم طول كرم
في هذه الصوره
نرصد التخريب والدمار الذي خلفه الاحتلال
في منازل الفلسطينيين هنا في وسط مخيم
تحديدا حاره الحمام التي شهدت انفجارات
واشتباكات مسلحه عنيفه بين قوات الاحتلال
ومقاومين على وقع العمليه العسكريه التي
تواصلت ل 46 ساعه نفذ خلالها الاحتلال
استهدافات مباشره للفلسطينيين بعض هذه
الاستهدافات كان بالطائرات المسيره التي
ادت لاستشهاد اربعه فلسطينيين في هذه
المنطقه هنا تم استهداف مجموعه من الشبان
كانوا يستقلون او بالقرب من مركبه تم
استهدافهم عبر طائره مسيره اسرائيليه ليتم
الاعلان عن استشهادهم بعد منع الاحتلال
لطواقم الاسعاف والهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
من الوصول الى اليهم ونقل هذه الجثامين
ثمانيه شهداء وفقا لبيان جيش الاحتلال
الذي اكد استهداف ثمانيه فلسطينيين في ما
اعتقل ما لا يقل بحسب ايه لجنه خدمات مخيم
طول كرم عن 50 فلسطينيا لا يزالون حتى هذه
اللحظه بين يدي الاحتلال وايضا اكثر من 15
اصابه بفعل استهداف الاحتلال المتواصل
لمخيم طول كرم من وسط مخيم طول كرم ليث
جعار الجزيره